i'd so i i suppose i haven't really
prepared
i think an actor has to be really
actually has to be able to soak up
a lot of things around i mean that's
where inspiration
comes from it has to come from someone
an old drama school quote of mine was
this thing of um
acting acting as reacting um
you can never indicate something you can
never push something
you have to be able to react to
something whether it's something inside
yourself
external ins inspiration
um a truthful action
on screen or stage is a reaction to
something that's when it becomes
spontaneous that's when it becomes real
and i find
with film you see because it's broken up
so much
because it's done so so much scene by
scene
it becomes very very it becomes very
very specific every moment becomes very
specific
so if for instance we're dealing with a
moment where
where his pride is hurt and he's
pretending that it's not by
perhaps being extrovert whatever
uh you needn't actually draw upon an
experience of
of in your own life where you were
actually in love
it could be last week you you can just
draw on that sensation or you mean
you just um
you just try and recall what you're like
when you're trying to cope with that
sort of thing
you can't just play in love you've got
to you've got to play how the character
copes with it
and um it was it was sorting that out
really
and and not and steering clear of of
cliches
well the classic theme of a love story
always seems to me if you look in
in in right through history if you look
at romeo and juliet for instance
it always seems to be a situation of
of people that can never actually have
each other they can never come together
and i think probably the nature of
romance is rooted in that
really there's nothing really romantic
about domestic bliss
you know there always has to be a
terrible problem there always has to be
external forces
interfering and uh seems invariably to
have to be tragic as well
and i think that's what appeals
basically i think um
absolutely everybody concerned seems to
be in one way or another's conspiring
against them i think it's it's something
which is
a dilemma when an actor is faced with
when playing a lover
there is the cliche of the sighing lover
and the sighing lover doesn't exist you
see i mean
the character is a human being who's in
love
um and you've got to find the
personality for the persons now i think
that
that they are inevitably fairly
lightweight
because i think that
that particular emotional state tends to
make you very lightweight
very much without much ballast and
aggression
but it was a question of finding out
where his pride lie
where his dignity lay where his um what
his safety mechanisms were
there was a period where a lot of people
a lot of friends of mine were sort of
watching waiting for me to change
you know and uh there starts to be a
lack of trust situation
whereby they start putting things that
you do
down to your success i mean if you
forget to phone somebody i mean it would
be hard you would go unnoticed before
but this time it's because
you haven't got time or if you say this
is a this place is boring it's
it's because you know it must be too
boring for you now because you're
successful whereas you can get away with
that
before um and that's a little bit of a
strain
i haven't been pacing myself really very
much i've um
sort of been a bit out of control lately
one thing's followed another and it's
still going and i'm
still going to april
and um in a way i
i i live off that actually i mean i i
don't know
what what it's going to be like when the
work stops but it's incredibly
exhilarating very tiring at the same
time
um but i'm having probably more fun now
than
i've ever had possibly and it's good to
just keep going
i'm it's exactly how i wanted at the
[Music]
moment
you